this morning police are searching for a
texas mother who mysteriously
disappeared before harvey hit crystal
mcdowell's last facebook post was stay
safe out there she wrote it the day
before harvey made landfall michelle
miller is in anuac texas where she spoke
with crystal's family michelle good
morning
good morning crystal mcdowell's family
says she was scheduled to pick up her
two children from her ex-husband's home
but never showed that was the day before
hurricane harvey flooded streets in her
neighborhood and with law enforcement
trying desperately to keep people out of
harm's way this storm may have provided
the ideal climate to cover a crime
see this black car right here
this mercedes
crystal mcdowell's car was found
submerged in this motel 6 parking lot
roughly 13 miles from her home the cops
were here busting indoors
to find out where this lady is police
say it was likely parked here before the
water rose
how confident are you that she was not a
victim of this storm
i'm very confident she is not a victim
of the storm we
feel very very confident that she's not
a victim of this storm these are the
last known images of crystal taken from
security cameras in her boyfriend's home
and a day before the hurricane she was
leaving for two appointments as a real
estate agent her office could not
confirm whether or not she made either
one and our main objective is just to
get crystal
back hope
crystal's uncle jeff walters works in
the same real estate office what do you
think happened to her i don't know but i
know that she's not one to leave and
she's
she would always be in contact with us
and her children chambers county sheriff
ryan hawthorne says the investigation
began before the storm but harvey's
aftermath has made their efforts more
challenging we are hampered by some of
the flood issues but we are as
aggressive as ever trying to locate and
find
crystal mcdowell the 38-year-old mother
of two was divorced in june but still
shared a home with her ex-husband
stephen mcdowell
our calls to mcdowell went unanswered
but he told crystal's relatives she
intended to pick up the kids and ride
out the storm in dallas i think she was
concerned for her well-being paul
hargrave says he and crystal started
dating in june after her divorce and
suggests the relationship with her
ex-husband was not an amicable one i
think she was wanting to get out of that
situation as quickly as possible and
move forward i think that
there was probably some
animosity between
boyfriends and husbands and the husband
probably might think the boyfriend had
something to do with her boyfriend might
think the husband had something to do
with which is exactly what we're faced
with right now now sheriff hawthorne
knows that this family wants answers and
they want them fast but he says
resources here simply stretch thin in
fact
two of the investigators on this case
have been flooded out of their homes
michelle that sounds very sinister
sounds like a story for 48 hours the
bottom line is children are missing
their mother that's a very sad story
thank you michelle very much